Platonic...
Oh God, I wish...
It means that you are just...
platonic.
I don’t know where the word
comes from.
Plato.
Oh, Plato.
Plato only ever got friend-zoned
It was really fun being back on
set collaborating.
It’s fun to work together.
Dorito-saurus.
It was part of the pitch.
Yeah, it was part of the thing.
Yeah, it wasn’t like
“Guess what, they cast Rose!”
Platonic is a TV show
about a man and a woman who were
very good friends and
they haven’t spoken in years.
And then they reconnect.
There’s a reemergence into each
other’s lives at very different
points.
Sylvia is a mother of three.
Will was Mommy’s best friend.
Like an ex?
No, just a friend.
With benefits?
No! Ew!
What?
Will is a newly single guy
and he runs a brewery.
She’s gone for five years...
Mhm.
And now she’s back.
Yes.
Can’t be friends with a girl.
That is absolutely not true
the whole movie When Harry Met
Sally is dedicated to
proving the fact that you can be
friends with a woman.
No, Will, that’s a bad example.
Harry marries Sally.
They’re not friends.
It’s so rare that there’s that
kind of
dynamic on television.
And just really funny.
Can’t we just have fun like we
used to have?
What are we gonna do? What are
we gonna do for fun?
Your friendship with Will...
Wooo!!
Stay.
...is not built...
...for this phase of life.
Whoa.
Send me the invoice.
There’s no, like,
will-they-won’t-they.
Will-they-won’t-they.
Don’t look at my ass
unless you wanna get hypnotized.
With all due respect I do not.
Just go!
Nothing between the sheets.
That is the fundamental bedrock
of their relationship.
You’re a good friend.
Yes. Yes I am.
But no funny business.
It was easy to kill any, uh,
sexual tension between us.